rideaux de fer baissés vitrine défiguré
par les affiches de liquidation 12000
commerce aurait fermé depuis le début de
l'année près d'un espagnol sur quatre
est au chômage
l'économie que l'on citait encore en
exemple il ya cinq ans s'est effondré à
madrid le quartier dit de la prospérité
porte mal son nom
c'est ici que césar officie depuis
quinze ans à la tête d'un bazar qui va
lui aussi fermé sur son tee shirt
il a écrit fermeture pour cause de
désespoir il faut dire que son magasin
fait travailler toute sa famille
je vous présente pablo mon fils aîné
c'est un élément important de l'équipe
ici chacun a son rôle
[Musique]
les enfants sont dans les rayons la
caisse est tenu par leur maman alicia
les ventes du magasin ont baissé de 30 %
en trois ans ses clients n'achètent plus
que le strict nécessaire
par exemple ce cadre photo qui pourrait
remplacer celui que j'ai chez moi eh ben
je le prends pas c'est joli petit as non
plus aujourd'hui j'ai juste pris des
cuillères pour remplacer celles qui sont
cassé chez moi et des ciseaux l'avenir
de la famille de césar est aujourd'hui
très flou lui c'est mon petit fils c'est
la prochaine génération d'entrepreneurs
de la famille mais il n'aura plus le
bazar de son papy sanon qu'il fera
difficile à dire
son père peut-être vous en dira plus
c'est david un jeune père qui n'est pas
sûr d'avoir un avenir en espagne
j'ai terminé cette année mes études pour
devenir prof de sport je vais chercher
dans ce domaine si je ne trouve pas
faudra que je me débrouille et s'il faut
émigrés bien j'ai migrerait comme au
siècle dernier
les espagnols se remettent à émigrer la
soeur de david vient de s'installer aux
pays bas toute la famille envisage de la
rejoindre ou peut être de venir en
france
face à la crise chaque espagnol
improvise pour survivre rien qu'à madrid
il y aurait 60 expulsion par jour qui
déclenche souvent la colère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas un immeuble qui n'est au moins un
appartement en vente est souvent
beaucoup plus en espagne plus encore
qu'en france l'état comme les
particuliers sont trop endettés le pays
n'inspire plus confiance aux marchés
financiers
alors désormais les espagnols payent
beaucoup plus cher leurs emprunts et ça
peut tourner à la catastrophe